ITV we're looking for one half-hour show
to fill this one Gap in the city of the
screenwriter and I met when we were both
students at Oxford and we had already
done some visual sketches I had
discovered by then I suppose that I can
express myself without words Church
sketch was the first Mr Bean sketch we
had an idea it seemed rich and we would
just sit in a room and say well what's
the next thing that could happen with
the resources that we've got he's a
character who's furthest away from my
own character I think he's very odd and
pretty weird and not very nice
he didn't have to have a name because
there were no words spoken we had to
give him a name in order to give the
television show a name we were thinking
Mr White for a while that was an idea
but that sounded a bit dull and Mr Bean
seemed to be short sharp and to the
point
babe